♪
- NOICE!
NOICE!
♪
- NOICE!
- [laughs]
- EXCUSE ME, EXCUSE ME.
'SCUSE ME.
'SCUSE ME, 'SCUSE ME.
'SCUSE ME, 'SCUSE ME,
'SCUSE ME.
'SCUSE ME,
'SCUSE ME, 'SCUSE ME.
- WHAT'S UP, BOY?
WHAT'S UP, BOO?
- YO, WHAT YOU DOIN'?
- I'M JUST NOICIN' THE NOICE!
- WELL, DON'T.
IT'S MOSTLY
ABOUT THE DANCERS.
- OH, YEAH.
- BESIDES, YOU KNOW,
I'M KIND OF THE GUY
THAT SAYS, "NOICE!"
- NOICE!
- WHA--WHAT HAPPENED?
- NOTHING HAPPENED,
I JUST NOICED YOU
BECAUSE YOU STAND UP
FOR YOURSELF
AND YOUR PLACE
IN THIS DANCE CIRCLE.
- NO, NO.
NO "NOICE," OKAY?
"NOICE" IS MY THING.
NO MORE "NOICE" FROM YOU.
'SCUSE ME, 'SCUSE ME,
'SCUSE ME.
'SCUSE ME, 'SCUSE ME.
♪
AW...
AW, NOICE!
[cheers and applause]
♪
NOICE?
[sweeping dramatic music]
♪
[exhales]
'SCUSE ME.
NOICE!
[panicked]
NOICE! NOICE!
NOICE!
[lightning crashes]
NOICE.
[dramatic music]
- NOICE.
♪
- YOU...
NOICE?
♪
- [crying]
NOICE.
♪
- [exhales]
- [sighs]
♪
- NOICE.
- NOICE!
[cries]
- NOICE.
NOICE.
- NOICE!
[both crying]
both: NOOOICE!
- NOICE!
♪
- THIS IS THE FIGHT
EVERYBODY'S BEEN WAITING FOR,